it's getting pretty scary to fly in Joe
Biden's America
shocking video shows Flames spewing from
the engine of a Southwest Airlines plane
and it just taken off from Houston to
sunny Cancun the aircraft Landing safely
and has been taken out of service and if
that doesn't scare you out of flying a
stunning new FAA report reveals there's
been a staggering 46 close calls in the
last month alone some fear it's only a
matter of time before something deadly
happens a shortage of error traffic
controllers could be to blame according
to the Wall Street Journal quote the FAA
has failed to train enough new
controllers to replace those who are
quitting or retiring so what's mayor
Pete doing about it well he promised
months ago that he was on the case
as we look at the recent incidents of
the last year or so and as NTSB and FAA
continue to investigate we can't wait
for the next catastrophic event to seek
the warning signs of today fully
determine the contributing factors and
swiftly address them what have you flown
recently and did you find it unsafe in
any way
oh you're asking me I am asking you uh
well I did just share with you here's
what I think there's some something's
happening you know you've got demand way
up you've got prices that have come down
you've got people post pandemic wanting
to travel you have Pilots that are now
too busy in some cases we love our
Pilots but they're not showing up for
work they're demanding more pay the
airlines aren't always meeting that
demand they are chronically understaffed
particularly when it comes to the towers
um where they obviously direct all the
traffic and this is essential for
landing and taking off the plane safely
there are facilities in New York and
Philadelphia that are staffed at 60
percent or less and you know what
happens then you can't operate at less
than what you're supposed to be at what
do they do mandatory overtime so now
it's being reported that the demands of
the job have left some burnt out even
using alcohol and sleeping pills to
relieve their stress this is a this
could be a deadly combination I'm not
trying to scare people but I mean take
it all in there could be a disaster in
the works have you noticed the same
thing when you've been at the airport
I've certainly noticed the delays and
the fact that there aren't flights that
you would think that you could get
easily like I need to go to Dallas in
the evening which used to be super easy
it's an American Airlines hub now now
there isn't a flight past eight o'clock
to go and do that I was searching every
Airline Southwest as the one that has
one available anyway
um I'll see you on Southwest but um
there was an IG investigation into this
and they found that 77 percent of air
traffic control facilities across the
country are understaffed at this moment
so we lost a lot of people out of covet
and the trend line was starting before
that I think like the highest peak that
we had was in 2012 that was obviously a
lot before covid came but they have to
find a solution to this I mean this is
something and you know I I tend to
defend the administration but mayor p
secretary Pete I'm sorry
um needs to find some decent solution to
this and you have to find the money to
pay people more you have to find a way
to recruit people to come to these jobs
which usually is directly related to how
well that you're paying them because
it's dangerous does Mayor Pete have a
plan to address this judge don't ask me
don't ask me about mayor Pete I mean
look here's the problem covet led to a
training delay apparently and as a
result of that they haven't caught up
now to me that's stupid okay if there
was a training delay then I double it at
this end if they say you can't you to be
an applicant to be a flight in their
traffic controller you have to be under
31 and retire at 56. okay why are they
forcing people to retire at 56 change
the age to 60. okay
and now what they're talking about is
raising the age of the pilots as well
because they they limit them and it's
true there's alcohol drugs are doing
everything they can to try to make sure
that they're awake at least applying
alcohol is not going to help that yeah
no I know that but they they are they're
just trying to survive 40 of the delays
occur in the New York area okay they
originate in the New York area what does
that tell you
um it would seem that we're a Democrat
State we should be able to get some
money from the federal government but um
the FAA is apparently requesting more
for training hiring technology but you
know what requesting it is one thing
he's a Cabinet member he should be able
to get it done but I don't know if he's
interested in that if you say
robot Pilots I'm gonna punch you with
love how did you know that's all I have
I said we don't know what the close
calls are they says there's roughly 50
but there are two words to explain them
human error you know who doesn't have
training deficits robots machines yeah
this phone never acts funny yesterday
yeah but yesterday we talked about yeah
you went into a little panic over
self-driving cars
after the show I found you in the Green
Room weeping you were weeping I
was true but the fact is you know knock
on wood a lot of these issues are small
right now you got delays you got fights
that's what we're seeing because we have
a lot of people flying uh but the fact
is I would still rather fly than get on
the West Side Highway at eight o'clock
there's a hell of a lot of Destruction
going on that people who are we because
we have fewer law enforcement there's
people driving like maniacs and
everybody knows is wherever you are and
then you've seen the fatalities go up so
it's still safer to fly I think we're in
a desperate uh hiring phase because
we're almost at full employment
everybody you could employ is being
employed so you do have to ramp up the
training so there are um there are some
uh actual practical things you can do
that I'm offering but at the bottom it's
always going to go back to the when
humans are in charge they make mistakes
you need the robots to take over okay so
you will fly on a robot plane I already
do we already
fly themselves okay
okay you do Greg they apply themselves
the guys in the cockpit are just hanging
outside I got onto a plane and they were
all drunk
I'm joking my is it sober I think you
weren't talking about Southwest
coming up Liberals are making your kids
Dumber we'll explain hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else